for Mad Roy and back to fala fala from the left
Circle a shot Grace the outside of that short
side post you can hear the Ping from up here
Washington Capitals gain the line work the puck
down L mantha centers in a shot in type handled
by Cam talit that chance by protus pinching Jens
on the right side the veteran Nick Jensen her
protus walking out spinning a weak forehand
shot in tight katar's line back out against ketov
and oetkin here's Kee behind the back to Byfield
shoots save has made rebound reaching for copar
couldn't get the puck obey cuell spinning behind
to the king's neck for down and up high it comes
shot through traffic gloved by talbat dubba looks
in front feeds it down low in the right corner
runstrom away with it turns his shot High save
made almost caught lingren by surprise right
there and in for the puck England ahead to Spence
Spence for fala fala a shot save made with the
glove if they do get a pop power play chance
we'll keep our eye on that love to see it in the
warm up not the game Dy a shot went off kopitar's
body and wide and here is Alex oetkin shoted in
and then ran over Mikey Anderson dowy around four
Anderson the Kings defenseman and up the wall Kee
for dowy in the Kings to Center Kopitar for Kee
Kee stopping up looking for a play to the trailer
Anderson a shot off the glove of the goenda net
KV up the Middle with the Anderson Dolan sandine
broke up the play Spence left side England with
a shot wide off the boards CF [Applause] scores a
great bounce off the end Dasher to Arthur cev one
nothing La an England right there that changes
everything now you get into a situation where
the balance works now you know how many goals
Cali have scores like that it's almost like
he he just finds pucks yes he does lingin has
looked a little bit confused that time with the
puck down low but I'll give him this you rarely
see us Anderson Dolan still out there couldn't
control the puck along the boards and now the caps
with numbers to the net a pass across and they
score the capitals talked this morning about
beating the neutral zone for the Kings the
Kings have the puck all of a sudden very quick
right there that one pass beats three kings
it was one of those situations where it didn't
develop by Design but then all of a sudden the
two-on-one is there McMichael a former first
round pick here's fiala a bouncing Puck had
it gets it back shoots in tight oh great hand ey
coordination on display there there by fiala Deno
pressuring farari who swings it around the left
wing boards and melen Stein will clear it ahead
to the Kings line picked up on the right side
and a shot tipped on and his future very much
up in the air now a turnover Byfield forar oh
rolled off his stick into the captain Kopitar
Kopitar in deep palala out to Kopitar into the
right Circle fala at the goal line where it's
centered right to the blue paint by Moore he tried
to get it to Deno and the Kings on a power play CV
reaching Fort couldn't make a play Carlson's pass
a little give and go moves in to the net a chance
save is made Puck still loose and then covered
by talet oh big hit barari on Byfield we play
on Wilson a sh blocked loose in front oetkin a
chance and that's stopped oetkin first look and
McMichael Off to the Races for Washington that's
a track meet right now back and forth mantha to
McMichael in on goal a pass backhander mantha save
made fala with Roy jumping up fala into the middle
fala shoots block backhander gabov is blocked
aside Jensen save made rebound pushed ahead off
to the races Kee in decks save is made rebound by
field couldn't find the handle as lafier Banks it
ahead for dubba to pick up dubba driving wide
on Carlson moves in a chance save is made oh
a power move by PL for dowy and to fiala across
to Kee one time did wide Kings regroup dowy for
Byfield his pass right in front and a chance
on a deflection off Kopitar but l holds the
fort his Nets off oetkin Wilson one shot on
goal oetkin earlier in the period copard Kee
Love Save made and McMichael walks out holding
on backhander Save is made as tbot came charging
out at McMichael cap still with it in front a
chance man the save they score on the rebound
McMichael and Washington has a two to one one
lead MC Michael has been by far the best player
for the Washington Capitals here's the play where
he has to hold on he has to hold on Bang there he
is just out of the air it's the constant pressure
of the [Applause] capitals C Calin forc to makes
that first one and then Michael just comes in
behind so the Caps away with it mantha has the
Cap's first goal tonight McMichael the second
mantha chance in tight sprawling save injury to
Edmonson but they've got the six they want to see
night after night shoo in Wilson off the boards
Couldn't Shoot oetkin does and he stop by Talbert
for Byfield Chris crosses with kopar feeds kopar
in front to Byfield a chance save is made Kee down
low to England heading for the at couldn't get
the puck Kings Battle to keep it in they do kempe
spinning kempe feeds it across score Andre kopar
with another onetime and the game is tied that
was broken on a play looks like we're going to
get a review here which is not making me happy
here because it looks like it's linesman over
offside is normally high percentage we'll wait
to hear yeah Lille with a headset on Washington
has elected to use its coach's challenge for
offside watch coper come slow it down guys
slow oh sorry about that yeah sorry my producer
Hoover is telling we don't have control of this
but you'll see 11 go over the line perhaps before
the puck the puck is going to be over here kopar
is going to come in this [Music] way and that's
that's what they're looking at it look to me that
it is offside Kopitar goes over upon video review
the play on the ice is deemed to be no goal please
reset the clock up top gabov a shot never got
through more battles feeds the middle gabov
to Dy save is made loose P block as they try to
tie this one up at crypto.com Arena for Byfield
Byfield to kiy save rebound save still it's behind
the net kempe robbed twice Spence to kempe kempe a
shot blocked by Dow the forwards have blocked
so many shots here campe walking out shooting
hit the crossbar kopar for Dy Bann on a shot three
seconds left another attempt blocked more centers
blocked and fittingly that's the way the game
should end for Washington with a blocked shot